if you could go back to 26 years old
this one's for you what is the first
thing you would master and this is
actually from Ivan who gave us the
costumers yes look everyone that you
asked this question will give you a
different answer right you know some
people tell you to have a Specialties
have a skill you know
networking social status you know
connections whatever it is so all I can
do is speak from a position of strength
that I've done yeah
um when I was 26 I was my brokest friend
okay by the time I was 35 I was one of
my wealthiest friends okay interesting
what happened
between 21 let's just talk about in
college graduating college between 21
and 26 I was not focused on money so you
know they say you know jack of all
trades master of none what you need to
do is that niches you know the riches
are in the niches be a specialist I
didn't become a specialist until I was
in my late 20s or I started at 26 27 but
I spent
21 to 26 being the consummate networker
um connections Galore but we're going to
go for that because today it's hard yeah
well obviously everything you know was
done back then you know back in the day
um there was no social media you know in
the early to mid 2000s but still today
you don't have to be on social media in
order to network social media is great
connections follows that's great but
until you meet somebody in person all
out like the dating reference we just
did you're never gonna have the vibe
you're never gonna have a real
connection So my answer to this question
is develop the soft skills not the hard
skills how to interact with people how
to interact in a meeting how to have a
dinner with somebody I go to business
dinners with pbd all the time right all
the time because he knows that when I go
to dinner we're gonna have a good time
we're gonna have a good conversation I'm
going to treat the guests with respect
I'm not going to kiss his ass though I'm
gonna operate in a sense where after the
dinner the guest is like yeah that guy
sounds pretty cool bro like what's his
deal so I have a question for you where
did you like learn the so that way to
interact because some people can go and
go network but they don't know how to
network like they'll just go there and
just like listen maybe ask a question
too how do you like be a
productive networking networker
um in the outside wherever yeah some
people got it and some people don't
let's just start with that some people
are extroverts and they thrive in a
social environment that's me
introverts not so much they're they're
like scared when they go out into public
like this and that's fine okay but it's
all about intention so my intention it
used to be to meet as many people as
possible
have you know create a great Vibe show
interest in other people if you've ever
read the book uh How to Win Friends and
Influence People right remember people's
names treat people with respect
appreciate that's great if you're the
type of person who's an extrovert and
this flows naturally to you and you're a
social butterfly the world's your oyster
but if you're an introvert let me speak
to the introverts out there if you're an
introvert you need to be very
intentional with your time you'll be
very intentional when you walk into a
room because you're scared you're
intimidated I don't know what I'm doing
here you need to say all right my goal
is to make three Connections three
connections like me when I would go into
a room of hundreds of people I'm like
I'm trying to get as many business cards
as possible I'm trying to shake as many
hands as possible I'm trying to be that
guy that everybody remembers cool and
that works well for extroverts you're a
floater but people can tell if you're
being fake so there's a fine balance if
you're an extrovert between hey I'm a
good networker I'm appreciative I'm
respectful versus like I'm a tryhard
yeah never cool to be a tryhard so
what's the mindset going like if
somebody's going to go and Network an
event like what are some of the things
they should be thinking about like going
like the outcome what is what should
their outcome be looking towards okay so
um
it's all about intentions so
um as far as outcome goes well number
one before you show up like look good
like if you're going to a networking
event and you're just showing up and
you're kind of the sloppy guy or you
kind of like you got food on your face
you're slop it's just people like doing
business with people they like one of
the things I've learned whether you're
in the real estate business whether
you're in the financial services whether
you're an entrepreneur whether you're
working
Tech whatever it is
we're in the people business people like
doing business with people they like yes
so if you're you know when you're it's
it's all about it when I go to
networking events I understand all right
like because think about it
let's say I don't know if whether you're
traveling or not right regardless so a
lot of times like what I would do is I'd
live in Miami yeah but I would like I
met Pat in Texas at a networking event
so
something needs to shift meaning all
right I'm on a flight or I'm driving
someplace okay cool I'm talking to my
girl I'm talking to my friends I'm doing
my thing once I step into the lobby or
the hotel or the business conference
whatever it is it's flip the script all
right I'm in networking mode my phone
all the other [ __ ] that I'm dealing
with you know
family drama girlfriend drama friends
stuff whatever Social Media stuff phone
off I'm here and I'm very clear on why
I'm here I'm here to Network I'm here to
socialize I'm here to be remembered I'm
here for people to remember me I'm here
to meet people and create connections
and then what happens is a trickle-down
effect all of a sudden you're that guy
like what I do is like I differentiated
myself from all the people in the
financial services world like Pat's
world everything everyone sells life
insurance you know this very well PHP
yes so people said oh what do you do you
hear the life insurance conference oh
you know how these people are all
selling life insurance yeah I'm buying
life insurance people are like what does
that mean it's like everyone here is
selling you something I'm here to buy
your life insurance off of you for cash
today people are like what are you
talking about yeah so we have a fund
that basically it's almost like
structured settlements or reverse
mortgages we're gonna pay you capital
for your asset so that's a
differentiator but you need to be very
intentional with what you're doing back
to me back to being an introvert there's
people that are watching this online
you're like dude I've never been to a
networking event in my life I'm not good
at this kind of stuff
go with three goals in mind I want to
meet three people that I can do
something with and then three turns into
five and five turns into ten it tends
into twenty and then play the long game
you're not gonna just kill it in one
meeting yeah but show up look good have
a great attitude one of the things I
always say about Nat is she's got a
great attitude she comes into the office
bubbly fresh people want to be around
her that's attractive that's an
attractive quality you know again even
if you're an introvert you don't want to
be there like I don't want to freaking
be here
act accordingly yes so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
saucecast click right here
[Music]